dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here imagine
the following we put an object on a
robot arm and the input is a recorded
video of it and the output would be the
digital geometry and the material model
for this object this geometry and
material model we can plug into a
photorealistic light simulation program
to have a digital copy of our real-world
object first we have to be wary of the
fact that normally solving such a
problem sounds completely hopeless we
have three variables that we have to
take into consideration the lighting in
the room the geometry of the object and
the material properties of the object if
any two of the three variables is known
the problem is relatively simple and
there are already existing works to
address these combinations for instance
if we create a studio lighting setup and
know the geometry of the object as well
it is not that difficult to capture the
material properties also if the material
properties and lighting is known there
are methods to extract the geometry of
the objects however this is a way more
difficult formulation of the problem
because out of the three variables not
two not one but zero are known we don't
have control over the lighting the
material properties can be arbitrary and
the geometry can also be anything
several very sensible assumptions are
being made such as that our camera has
to be stationary and the rotation
directions of the object should be known
and some more of these are discussed in
the paper in detail all of them are
quite sensible and they don't feel
limiting the algorithm works the
following way in the first step we
estimate the lighting and leaning on
this estimation we build a rough initial
surface model and in the second step
using this surface model we see a bit
clearer and therefore we can refine our
initial guess for the lighting and the
material model however now that we know
the lighting a bit better we can again
get back to the surface reconstruction
and improve our solution there this
entire process happens iteratively which
means that
first we obtain a very rough initial
guess for the surface and we constantly
refine this piece of surface to get
closer and closer to the final solution
and now feast your eyes on these
incredible results and marvel at the
fact that we know next to nothing about
the input and the geometry and material
properties almost magically appear on
the screen this is an amazing piece of
work and lots and lots of details and
results are discussed in the paper which
is quite well written and was a joy to
read make sure to have a look at it the
link is available in the video
description also thanks for all the kind
comments have experienced a recent
influx of emails from people all around
the world expressing how they are
enjoying the series and many of them
telling their personal stories in their
relation to science and how these new
inventions are being talked about over
dinner
with the family and relatives it has
been such a delight to read these
messages thank you and also thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you